we had brought a principal to a large
venue
in las vegas for a ufc fight kind of all
hell broke
despite thousands and thousands of
people we had to get this person who was
very close to the ring out of there very
quickly
you that's why planning is so very
important but that's somebody i gotta
have my eye on
what do you look for first thing
obviously anyone who you do have a volvo
for
be on the lookout you have information
on someone you're always scanning for
that
if they show up at an event that's a
problem you have to address immediately
wherever you are you should have a
heightened sense of awareness with those
people because they're they're erratic
and you're not sure what might happen
communication skills handle the stress
think quick
and mitigate do the best you can to
accommodate the principle
most of this job is communications and
understanding how to handle people
good judgment calls so much more than
firearms proficiency
and mixed martial arts it really
communications and good judgment is the
most important
weapons we have we don't stay and fight
that's not what we do so if someone
pulls a gun
we get that principle in the vehicle and
we're out of there as fast as possible
we don't care about the aftermath our
job is to get that principle out there
not stay and have a firefight
[Music]
so my guest today is a bodyguard and i'm
not talking about kevin
costner from the movie bodyguard with
whitney houston i'm talking about
real life bodyguard a certified
bodyguard he runs a
company he's a ceo of global threat
solution
a retired army intelligence officer
united states army captain
and he's a bodyguard to celebrities
presidents politicians all walks of life
with that being said
kenneth bombus thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment
thank you thank you thank you for having
me on your show i'm really looking
forward to this
so so i'm curious so you know kids grow
up we say oh i want to be a baseball i
want to be the next mickey man i want to
be the next jeter i want to be the next
this i want to be lebron kobe jordan
who wakes up and says you know dad mom
when i grow up i want to be a bodyguard
well to answer that question uh i didn't
wake up and
say that i uh you know since i was five
years old
i consider myself very lucky that i knew
what i wanted to do
i wanted to go in the military wanted to
go into law enforcement i want to be a
police officer
and i've done both of those so it was
uh during those careers that led me to
creating my own company
and and operating as a protection firm
you know uh primarily at the end of my
law enforcement career last six years i
led
protection operations one of the largest
police departments in america
and that's what kind of led me to think
that i really enjoyed the work it was
it's challenging
it's a lot of uh it's definitely a
thinking man's game
and i enjoyed the work got a great deal
of experience they sent me to a ton of
great training i've been trained by some
of the uh
by blackwater i've been trained by
federal law enforcement
training center i've created a program
to train people through the police
department
and uh i enjoyed the work and then i
also when i retired
i was uh 45 years old and i saw the
opportunity
of starting my own firm to do this type
of work and
that's what i've done so so in the
in the you know position of being a
bodyguard going back to
yourself saying you always knew you were
going to be a cop or you were going to
go into military law enforcement
did you have a were your parents in it
was an
uncle was a grandfather was it like you
looked up to your father so much we're
like one day i want to be a cop
uh so partially my father was in the air
force he wasn't in law enforcement he
was an air traffic controller his whole
career uh and did that for many years
went into leadership
but ever since i was young uh i was i
was
taught uh i guess mostly by observation
my parents i'll tell you probably more
so than my father who is a great patriot
who is my my mother
who is an incredible patriot and she's
me and hersey eye to eye to this day
and she's in her 80s and uh i knew that
i wanted to go in the military
since i was five and i knew that i
wanted to go
become a police officer and i'll just
say that the two go
sort of hand in hand a lot of people who
go into the military
end up transitioning into law
enforcement if you look at any police
department
a large one i know one in our department
at the time we had over 2600 officers
over 600 of them were veterans so it's
it's uh
the two careers it lends itself to a
career in law enforcement the
camaraderie the type of work
you know so i knew it both though that i
wanted to do both of those since i was
very young
five years old were you are you an older
brother uh no i'm actually the youngest
of five children
get out of here yeah the young so how is
the youngest
protective because to do what you want
to do you got to have a protective dna
were you
always the guy that kind of protect you
wanted to protect people was that part
of your dna
i i love the idea of it since as long as
i can remember i think that's what
probably um the attraction to the
military
you know was was attract defending
people protecting people that couldn't
protect themselves the same thing with
law enforcement ever since i was young
i guess you know i grew up in the 70s i
would watch
movies war movies i'd watch dirty harry
was my
my favorite movie probably still is all
of them and i'm just turned 50 years old
this year
so uh you know it was a culmination of
things but i would say that that
uh i knew i wanted to be in the military
law enforcement
was just it goes hand in hand the two
work together and uh
it's great that i've been able to do
both in a parallel career i
initially of course at 18 the day after
high school i went in the military
i i joined when i was 17 as soon as i
was allowed to
to join and uh you know i served in the
military
military and then that transitioned into
eventually a a law enforcement career
with a parallel reserve forces military
career got it
got it uh and your your siblings did
they ever go in the military or no were
they any any one of them law enforcement
or military
no no it's just you're the only one yeah
got it interesting okay so so then by
the way back in the days when i left the
army the first
i got a job offer this is what's funny i
got a job offer
for 28 800 a year at fort lauderdale
police department to be a cop right but
i live in california and i was in uh
kentucky at the time i'm like i don't
even know where fort lauderdale is now
you know i'm
20 miles away from fort lauderdale today
then
when i went back my dad said patrick you
know
people like you who are big and
intimidating you need to go be a cop
you know with this tony robbins speech
you know you need to go be a cop so
i want to apply to 21 years old i
applied to be
lapd uh i passed obviously
the stuff that you need to pass but they
don't like 16 speeding tickets so that
that
was what hurt me from being a cop or
else
i would have also been a cop but you're
right military typically leads to
going into that side firefighter you
know there's some areas because you get
that additional 10 points that they give
you i don't know what it was it was a
certain
time you get for the test that you take
anyways let's transition to being a
bodyguard so
you know you've been in this space of
bodyguard
you know it's your business that's what
you do protection what are
if you notice a trend especially today
who are you noticing calling you telling
you
hey i need protection are you noticing a
trend with industries
are you noticing a trend with you know a
certain level of success are you
noticing a trend or is it all over the
place there's not like
48 of our clients that make a call to us
they're from et cetera
et cetera what are you noticing on who's
giving you a call meaning your ideal
customer that calls you
so right i'll tell you what's up you
always have celebrities
they always have protection mostly
especially you know your a-list
celebrities will have
uh bodyguards by the way we we call that
executive protection clause protection
bodyguard in our industry has almost
kind of looked down upon the term
because it's
it gives an image of maybe like almost
like a bouncer you know what i mean you
have someone who's like
300 pounds and stands at the door and
like i mentioned before
protection operations it's so much more
than that so much logistics and so much
um training and planning to go into it
but to get back to your question i'll
tell you that it's celebrities
definitely
uh corporate that's big so the way this
works
nowadays is a lot of uh corporations
once they
they go public a lot of times right in
the bylaws for those companies
they put in there that these certain
positions will have protection
and it's uh it's sort of works well for
the executives because it takes the
responsibility you know
having it a big expensive security
detail could be a liability as a
business person
politicians too um so what this does is
these companies are
saying listen you're saved for a c-suite
member you're the ceo of a big company
they'll say you're an asset you don't
have a choice you're getting this
protection
services anyone in that position gets it
got it
once you take that position you have a
an executive protection driver you have
residential security many of them
when i say executive protection it's not
just taking them out from morning to
their home for the evening of 24-hour
residential protection too
so you look at a lot of big companies
tech firms that i'm not going to give
names but
people would be so surprised because it
really is a niche
industry who has these they're like who
gets these services well
any big company you look at who has a
c-suite
and i'll say large company you know
companies definitely uh
500 million and and higher probably if i
were to throw a number on it
um they're gonna have some type of
protection for their
c-suite or uh senior executives and it
you know it's not doesn't necessarily um
relate to a direct threat level you know
like obviously a high-profile person
is going to have executive protection
some of the famous tech firms ceos
everybody knows right
um but also companies that you wouldn't
even know who the ceo is still
large companies but they're just not
that high profile um they have it as
well
and so corporate accounts are big in
this industry they will hire they will
often
subcontract companies to provide
services for them
uh and then celebrities is another one
and uh people of high net worth family
offices
they will also hire uh companies like
mine to provide those services
very interesting and it does make sense
so it's not really by choice sometimes
if it's
in if you're a ceo or high c suite
executive of a
40 billion dollar company they're gonna
say look john you know
this is you don't have a choice you
gotta have somebody we're hiring
somebody that's gonna protect you
because now you're an asset to the
company the
board wants you to be protected okay
check so that's one celebrities will
typically call and say hey
we're going here their team's gonna call
and say they're gonna need somebody fine
check that makes sense
residential you mean there are instances
where you are
pretty much what the client 24 7. there
are those instances as well
that's right 24 hours a day you know
that's a big vulnerability especially
when you have someone who's very high
profile we've all heard the stories
especially with celebrities somebody
could come on your property you can find
out where anybody lives these days right
no matter who you are
and uh they'll have 24-hour residential
protection
i'll be honest for someone who has a
full executive protection detail or a
protection detail
um more than not they're going to have
residential protection too
they're going to have someone there 24
hours a day
kenneth what's a what's a full-time
24 7 30 365 what does that
cost a client if they want 24 7
residential protection
all year long what does that cost per
year
per year i'd have to break that down it
depends on so many variables how many
agents you have in a detail
what is it typically so if you want to
say ideally typically it's two or three
what will you bring three but remember
then you might have 24-hour coverage
not one agent works seven days a week
and
you know you're talking 24-hour billing
millions you know definitely a few
million dollars you're gonna have for
someone have
year-long coverage it would start at
that level maybe two three million
dollars someone's gonna have 24-hour
residential protection
and a protection detail where they'd
have a driver and an agent you know all
are different some people might just
have one person
but you really you know um let's talk
let's talk about moving your we call it
a principle you're driving them around
right if you're the driver
sometimes they say no no we just need
one if you're the ep
driver we call it executive protection
driver and you're armed
you can't just jump out of that car and
go in places with them you can't
escort them in places so it's a big
vulnerability so oftentimes you'll have
a driver
and then you'll also have your your lead
agent that'll be a person sitting maybe
in the passenger seat
who's going to exit a vehicle and
they're going to accompany that
principle wherever they go
but by the way it's always dictated by
the principal
people like to you know you watch a lot
of tv a lot of movies
and people have this idea where um um
they a agent will say no sorry sir we're
not doing that because there's a risk
it you could go you could advise them
any way you want but ultimately the
principal's going to make that decision
and i'll be honest with you
that's all the way up to the president
you know um yes does it
did the secret service not want
president obama to suddenly say hey pull
over i want to go into this hamburger
place in washington dc
of course they said they'd rather him
not do that did he do it
yes so you know ultimately the
principals will make those decisions all
you can do is advise
them at the best you can and then you
mitigate it
okay he's gonna do it let's take steps
to mitigate any threats that might be
there
that's how it works they ultimately do
call the shots
so full time 24
7 residential protection
if these guys got to get their sleeve so
if you're doing 24 7
8 hours so it's like a rotation is a
rotation of three different uh
uh uh well that depends too so there's a
couple ways we bill in this industry
sometimes we do a daily flat rate which
we'll put a limit on that that would be
an
agent from morning to when they're in
for the evening and we bill them a daily
flat rate
because you have to make sure that that
agent is being paid according to
the laws of the state they're in
california as i'm sure you're aware
i've run details out that could be
expensive um because you know you have
agents anything over eight hours and
then 12 hours they're gonna make
overtime
and you have to accommodate for that so
we use we like to when possible
you don't want a lot of turnover eight
hour shifts are too short
uh for two reasons first of all um it's
easier for
staffing and scheduling to have an agent
twelve hours should do twelve hour
shifts
also your principal they don't like a
lot of turnover i haven't run a detail
yet
where they don't say listen every time i
go outside i see a new face
god they want to they want to get
comfortable with the people protecting
them
so you're never going to be able to do
it with one but you're going to try and
limit that number of agents you use for
a detail
so it's a balancing act you know you
want it to be efficient economical but
you also
don't want to have every time they walk
outside there's somebody new
you know it's interesting last year not
last year 2019 when it was still open we
had our event at the mirage and i
invited the late kobe bryant and
president bush so when president bush
came you know they have to call and say
hey he's coming he's speaking
secret service showed up everybody gets
that yellow you know what i'm talking
about that little
yeah you do and so that there was a
first time where the board said
we need somebody around you full time
right so they had somebody i'm the ceo
of the company so we had 7 000 people
there
convention you never know people are
walking competitors etc
so it was amazing that when the
executive protection from obviously
you you mentioned blackwater earlier
that's prince and he runs a
i don't know multi-billion dollar
company it's a very big operation i
think
one of my associates chris paronto i did
some projects for him but that was
overseas and also
some people that just use that company
for different kinds of
um services when the
executive protection guy came in and he
was
with me when they change it the first
day i said no i want the same guy so
they brought the same guy well the fee
is going to be a little bit hard if you
want to that sound
i want that guy there was a level of
comfort with them
that we brought him in and we brought
him in i said listen my wife and i are
having breakfast he was standing at the
duster do you mind just joining us he
says i
said just can you like he says well i
got to do my job myself you want to eat
something he says
so it was it was good talking making
some kind of a connection to know what
his background was
but it wasn't cheap on what we paid and
i remember that
what is the daily rate right now if you
were to say ball you know ballpark
high low give me the high low numbers i
know you said california so it varies by
state
give me a high low so i've built i like
to consider myself a uh
um a a company with fair rates
um so i build as low as we'll do a
thousand dollar daily flat rate for an
agent of course that's in addition to
expenses or anything you might have to
provide
if they need a vehicle if uh there's
lodging involved for the agent's travel
things like that
um but we i've built more than that
depending on the detail and there's
other companies that bill far more than
that two thousand dollars a day you know
they'll bill or more
for an agent so you know but we're in
the business
to be fair we we want to make sure we
pay our people well
that's the main thing so that you know
the really honestly the way we run our
companies our profit margin comes
secondary we have to make sure the
agents get taken care of
and i'll tell you another thing that is
becoming more and more important to
companies that contract you
they want to know they just don't want
to know what your billing rate is
you'll say especially some of the really
big high profile companies
social media companies they'll say
that's great what you're billing us
what are you paying your people are you
giving them health insurance they want
to know they want to know that you're
taking care of their
your people because that reflects on
them too because they're
yes it's a contract but it's working for
their firm
so uh so we the first thing is that and
then
you know you just want to make sure you
have a profit uh margin in there that's
fair for you and the client and that's
what we try and do
i'll tell you we're definitely i'd say
below average in the billing rate
for for some companies plus you'll have
companies that'll
for lack of a better word gouge you know
when you're going to do an initial
assessment
they'll say well you need this many
agents and you should have someone here
and someone here
yeah you do one of these assessments you
should be giving them the most
cost effective and um efficient option
you can that still provides them the
appropriate level of attack
protection it's very easy to say well
let's do 10 agents
because they know it's billable hours
right i think attorneys they know
they're looking at at
math rather than what this person really
needs so when you're saying millions of
dollars for executive protection 24 7
how many agents are you calculating that
would need to run there because
i did the math i'm like okay 168 hours
is there a limit on how many hours an
agent can work is it a 4
40 hour limit that you have that an
agent can work per week or is it 50 60
what number do you guys go based on
depends on the state you're working in
also if someone's
sometimes you use an independent
contractor maybe they have their own llc
so i'm billing them uh they're
developing four hours with that
and then it changes everything they're
no longer an employee right
yeah but when they're working as an
employee it depends on the state but for
the most part 40 hours is what you're
limited not
let me rephrase that not limited to but
you're going to be paying overtime
over that okay got it so and
that just goes by the state so so if
if we were to do the math i got my phone
in front of me so if i if i'm doing 24
7 protection does an average family only
have
one guy working at a time or do they
typically like two at a time
because it's not going to be a small
house they're not living at a small
house so it's probably going to be a
place where you need eyeballs
different places do they typically ask
for one or two
it's you know it's a difficult question
but i would say two would be an average
probably on you're talking an overnight
residential yes yes yes
so you know uh overnight residential
two would probably be an average some
have many more some will just have one
and then for detail during the day now
remember this
they're gonna have that during the day
too even when that
executive protection details traveling
with that principle bringing them to
work or events or wherever they have to
go
you're still going to have that 24-hour
protection at the residence even when
they're traveling there's somewhere else
that makes sense
because there's a vulnerability there
right so now it's almost like you have
two separate details that's exactly what
it's like you have your residential
protection agents
and then you have your executive
protection you can see how it adds up
quickly
and that's millions you're saying that's
that's a 200 million dollar bill per
year
yeah we had a client in california as an
example um
two principals we were protecting two
residences
and uh they had a driver and an agent
with them
and i could tell you it was between
three and four million dollars we were
billing a year gross
three to four million dollars and in
what okay so three
and that's not a that's not that was
only one residential agent at a time
and that's not a public like that's not
a politician you were talking about
that's it you know that's a business
business right so i'll be honest with
you most politicians
they're almost all they have government
protection
they're not going to have their own uh
security when it would come into place
is if someone leaves office and they no
longer have security
right um say like a vice president i've
done
i've done a d i was contracted my firm
to provide security
during democratic presidential forums
leading up to the election
all over the country we did them and uh
one of the candidates as we now know is
the current president
um president biden he would attend these
and he would have
uh he would have a private security with
him he no longer had
secret service protection so in that
scenario maybe
but when you're talking about anyone
from like a county executive
or a mayor or a governor um
they have day of police providing their
security executive protection like i did
when i was a detective
and i've worked with i've worked with uh
law enforcement members from
uh uh so many different governors and
mayors details we would all you know you
would all interact because politicians
interact
right so uh you would come across these
different details
and then it's funny because i've also
run into some of them who like me have
transitioned into the private sector
they're doing the same thing
god so so let me let me ask you this
question i i don't know how you would
answer this i've had clint hill on and
clinton uh was a secret service for
jackie kennedy and four other presidents
so he has a lot of stories
so you know they typically say like if
you go to the dmv
and you don't like the way they handle
you're getting a new license
registration no one is really going to
give you any kind of customer service
you go post a review on yelp no one
cares it's not like it's going to make
it up to the president why did you
mistreat a customer that came in right
versus you go to a restaurant and like
hey mary the hostess
gave an attitude to my wife and my kids
i didn't like it hey mary we have to
have a conversation what's this about
right so there's a little bit more
accountability
who's better at executive protection
secret service
or private you know uh executive
protection
companies that you go through so listen
uh i work closely with the secret
service wasn't a secret service agent i
was a detective
and they have their uh like a
partnership program it's like a liaison
program so
when they go to do security uh like they
would do in the hamptons in long island
when i was working
they had to work with police we provided
resources they didn't have
boats helicopters highway patrol lots of
bodies to do security
right so i work closely with them
they're great at what they do they are
the world
wide premier protection agency right
everybody
kind of respects them as that but i'll
tell you it's also very different
they have a lot of resources all the
time
and authority to do that you don't have
in the private sector
we're not shutting down express the long
island expressway
from with my company but i did it when
we were working with the secret service
they have benefits like that they could
bring in agents from all the different
states to work a big event
so so you know it's a that's an
impossible question many of the people
i've worked with in the private sector
were secret service agents
they that's what they did you know and
who come into my line of work so then
that means they would be though right
the guys who were former secret service
guys because they're bringing that
training
and they're bringing what they learn on
the public so if it's a former secret
service guy that's also working in the
public so he's going to have
a multi-dimensional experience and
somebody that just was secret service
oh of course yeah so that's what i would
say they you know the two are definitely
different there's not a secret service
agent that would tell you that
doing private sector uh security and
doing government work like that
very different but they come with an
incredible skill set and an experience
level
they know how it works they get that you
know executive protection is a customer
service
based business i always like to say when
we're training our agents
we do get bags you know that whole
attitude where we'll be like no i'm here
for security that's not the way this
works you know these are clients of ours
we're here to help them and whatever
they do within reason
you know we're not going to have people
doing ridiculous things so that
security is jeopardized but we're here
to work for the client and the secret
service really gets that
they've they work in that same type of a
manner with all of their principles
they've they've worked with
and and uh i would say that they have a
great
afterlife because you know that the name
secret service agent goes a long way in
the corporate world
you know or not just for executive
protection but becoming security
directors and working in corporate
security
people like that that title you know
that they bring with them on their
resume
do some of these guys come out and they
say you know i'd love to just
land a family and they
go live with the family they they get
the closer to a family
and the family pays them i don't know
150 200 250 300 000
a year and they're just like look kind
of like you know how somebody has a
nanny or your home
whatever you want to call it they get a
place in the back and you're getting
paid a quarter million just make sure
our family's protected when we travel
you go with us
is there those types of relationship as
well for some of these folks
oh i've heard everything the full
spectrum you know you have people that
might just be per diem agents protecting
someone when they come to visit new york
or las vegas or l.a
and then you have people that um they
bring in a relationship is very
important if they like you mentioned
earlier
if they have someone they really like
and like like you said you like the
agent i'd like that one to work tomorrow
that people will pay um top dollar and
they'll make accommodations for them
i've heard everything from a an
executive protection agent in the
private sector
there was someone hiding a very high net
worth who allowed him to use his cars i
mean ferraris
and things when when he was off off-duty
not working i mean
private sector that's what's nice about
it is um
there's no you know you don't have the
strict adherence to rules that you have
in the government work right peop they
are the boss they are the principal
and a lot of these people have
tremendous resources themselves and if
they really like someone
you know it's a fine line you have to
tread but they'll bring a moment
and they want them almost sort of like a
member of their family because they're
going to be around their children
they're going to be around their family
they're going to see them at their most
intimate moments
all the time so they want someone
they're comfortable with you know
there's just that fine line
as someone who runs an executive
protection firm that we want them not to
cross
where they uh you know you don't want an
agent that feels
if they're working for my company feels
like they're empowered because they have
a close relationship with a principal my
client
and they feel like they can call the
shots and tell me what's going on you
know
that's a challenge i think anyone who
has a company like mine has
for the most part the people we recruit
and train they get it they know where
their loyalty is
and uh and they will um they know how to
how to walk that line yeah very very
insightful because you know
you know most most most of us all we
know is movies
you know when you think about buying you
know movies you think about executive
protection you think about
hey in that movie with kevin costner in
that movie with liam neeson or in that
movie so
that's the interpretation we have it's
okay you know
you know but but in reality it's it's
slightly different on what happens
versus
in movies uh let me let me go a
different angle with you here on on this
this was very helpful
is what what are what are some
commonalities
amongst executive protection agents
that you'll say here's what they're very
good at and what is the priority
yesterday i interviewed a
sniper uh nicholas ingram
nicholas irving he had 33 confirmed
uh kills in afghanistan in 100 days and
i said tell me about you know
what are the trends of uh snipers are
they loners are they you know this are
they data and just kind of trying to be
is there like a trend with them
because you know engineers if you look
at engineers that are coding they're
quiet they put the headset on
they don't want to be around people
don't bother me you know let me just
kind of get to work and finish my
project
so with executive if you were to say
well if i was to
judge one from the top to bottom the
most important quality
is to have a feel for the room number
two is
you know being able to protect somebody
with
firearm firearm is more important than
actually fighting because we rarely
fight
being able to drive and escape and got
to be good in math got to be good at
common sense
how would you say like if you were to
say these are the five things we look
for for somebody to be very good at what
they do
so what i would say is communication
skills
is top your top tier it's a number one
priority with an agent that we recruit
you have to be able to communicate with
not only the principal
but their staff we're working with a lot
of staffers sometimes there are
like a right-hand person when we're
running these details you know
they're the one we're coordinating with
so
you need to have great communication
skills also equally as important
you have to be able to handle stress uh
well
if you can't handle stress this is
definitely not the industry for you
little things i'm not talking about
assassination attempts i'm talking about
making a wrong turn in new york city and
your principal has to be at a meeting in
10 minutes
that is real stress i could tell you um
in this business something that small
is critical making a wrong turn is
devastating
you know little things like that small
details can bring a lot of stress
also they'll change their plans you'll
have done an advanced site visit to
hotels to meeting venues all these
places you have their schedule
and then as you're driving they said we
changed our mind we want to go to this
location now
um in westchester county from manhattan
and and changes
everything while your agents is sitting
in that seat in the driver
you have to be able to react immediately
like that and mitigate
is that perfect do i have time to get
somebody up to that
venue and see it before we get there and
arrive probably not
you have to be able to think quick not
uh handle the stress
think quick and mitigate do the best you
can to accommodate the principle
so stress communication skills and also
for me uh you know we use law
enforcement people and we use military
i'll be honest i was both i love the
military people
because they have a mission first
attitude
i'm the first person to say i've worked
in law enforcement for over 20 years
sometimes a a union civil service
mindset can set inward people
and they'll be like oh listen i've been
working for 10 hours already
it's got to be mission first very
interesting what you just said right you
know i've had bernard carrick on before
and we had a great conversation and
him and i uh communicate every once in a
while and
it's it's very interesting how
you know different it is with military
and pd especially when union gets in and
you have to deal with politics and you
have certain
protection and it's makes your job a
little bit tougher so it's interesting
you're saying this so
so let me ask you this does it what if
i'm not a good fighter what if i don't
know how to fight does it even matter
the fact i'm a fighter like do i need to
be good at jiu jitsu boxing
because you know the impression is oh my
gosh that guy's an exhibit he's
could probably kick my ass what does
that rank
in the executive protection private so
right now you have communication stress
details think quick what does fighting
and
firearms come in him so here's what uh
i'll
i'll explain that first i'll say this
in um in protection services what we do
there's a thing called getting off the x
we don't stay and fight
that's not what we do um and it's a big
retraining
process we have to go through especially
for law enforcement you're a law
enforcement officer and you're in the
street and somebody pulls a gun
you run towards them there's going to be
a blue swarm right they're going to
tackle that person they're going to get
that gun
in our business we're we just get out as
fast as we can
our job is to get off the x the x being
the point of most danger so if someone
pulls the gun
we jump in we get that principle in the
vehicle and we're out of there as fast
as possible
we don't care about the aftermath i mean
look i don't want to sound
uncaring but my point is that's not our
job will we of course
relay any information to law enforcement
of course we would our job is to get
that principle out there not stay and
have a firefight not
staying wrestle with someone in the
streets that's not our job
so i'll say that first and foremost
with that being said do you need to be
able to protect
your principal of course you have to be
physically fit any martial arts training
is always beneficial
if as far as firearms i'll i'll say this
many probably the majority i've dealt
with in the united states are unarmed
details a lot of corporate executive
protection are unarmed
uh one reason for that is the crazy gun
laws we have in this country every state
has their own set of laws
right licensing licensing to carry
firearms license to do security work
every state needs its own licensing so
it's a it's a difficult pro
um requirement to get around so one
thing is a lot of it's unarmed
the other thing is let's say it is armed
or if you're in a high threat
doing high threat protection say
overseas protection you're bringing
someone maybe to the middle east
um or someplace in central or south
america maybe that's a high threat
region
um then you're going to want someone who
has that better that strong skill set
of of uh firearms proficiency
so what i i'll be honest with you when i
use armed
the vast majority of the people i use
armed in the united states
are former law enforcement you want to
know why because they come with their
training
wait please can you say that one more
time so so the vast majority of people
that i use that are armed are
former law enforcement what do you mean
by that domestically so in other words
you could have someone who just has a
armed security license and
a firearm and they've never been in law
enforcement
however what i what i i would say the
majority i i've hired people like that
the majority i use are former law
enforcement
when it's an armed detail first of all
it really is beneficial for all the
licensing requirements if they're a
former law enforcement officer
like myself i have hr 218 i could carry
a firearm anywhere in the united states
that's a a um
we can't do that only you can't it's not
something available to the public uh
no it's not right there's a co i'll get
off track for a second and say there is
a combination of per
licensing for a few different states
where if you get them
it gives day of reciprocity you can
carry in 44 states
what is it called it's like california
utah
and maybe nevada there's a couple of
states where if you get those my
operations manager knows because we're
familiar with it
if you get those licenses they have
reciprocity with other states and you
can carry in 44 states
however as you would guess new york
doesn't take part in any of those new
jersey doesn't take part in any
california i'm surprised california's on
them i mean i remember buying a job in
california
i had to wait 30 days to get the gun you
know texas you go in you leave five
minutes later
right right so california is one where
you have to have the california license
but if you have it in combination with
those others
it'll give you 44 states it's amazing
that california has that
yeah please continue i'm listening
yeah so so what i would say is i like
the law enforcement for the armed work
first of all
it's easy because you know they could
carry legally secondly
they come with their own firearms
training you know they've done
20 years most of the people i use are
retired 20 years minimum
of annual training some of them are in
specialized units they're comfortable
carrying a firearm
they it's they get it you know they're
they're it's they're
very comfortable with it they know where
it could go where it can't and how to
use it
so for that for that specific purpose
law enforcement is often used
for armed security work so so here's a
question for you what is the worst
situation you have been in yourself as
an executive protection or one of your
agents that reports to you and works for
you
what's been a case where you know
we were in a situation we're at a
restaurant we were on road you know all
of a sudden this is what happened and it
got ugly very quickly and we had to
figure out
obviously you can't disclose the name
but if you could disclose the situation
what would you say is the worst
situation you've been in so i'm going to
i'll tell you about um a few of them
right one of them was similar to what
you just said when we had brought a
principal
corporate principal to a uh large ven
uh uh high occupancy venue
in las vegas for a ufc fight and while
we were at there
doing security and our our agent was in
there with the principal we had agents
waiting outside
uh kind of all hell broke loose at this
fight where
we had to get this person who was very
close to the ring out of there very
quickly um so that's something that
could take is a real thing that could
happen when you're protecting a
principal
and you're talking about you know
thousands and thousands of people
you that's why planning is so very
important you need to know where you
have an egress route to get out of that
building
where is your vehicle stage to get them
in that vehicle and get them out quickly
that's one of them uh example like that
and we were successful but it was very
chaotic to get him out
um another one i had was a lar a very
high-ranking corporate executive i was
at a
venue a business um
forum and this person uh who i was
protecting
personally at the time because right now
i manage a lot of details but at this
time i was the
lead agent um sort of gave me
a look and and asked we were in the
green room and they asked me to come
over
um and they whispered to me
there's a person standing here in the
green room um
that is a known stalker who's been
following me
and now this was not a fault of mine for
not recognizing this because it was i
was never giving what we call ebola
who are the company that hired me never
provided me with this information
that there was in fact someone who's
been following them
usually if someone if there's a known
entity and often there is
high profile business executives they'll
have many people that they keep an eye
on they track
because they've made threats they show
up at a lot of their events it's common
got it i was not given that intelligence
also
the person had legitimate press
credentials so you know
they were allowed in there that's
another problem you'll find in security
these days
is that press credentials are easy to
get you could have a blog
and somebody will issue you some type of
a press credential you could get pretty
close
access to people um so
that was it was a successful mission and
as i was told this the person had took
off she
uh the uh person in question the subject
saw me walking over talking to the
principal and fled
but i had two other agents out in the
audience who through my description
and me talking to them in the radio
located the person followed him back
into the forum
we were able to get local law
enforcement to show up waiting for them
and they walked out
and it was a complete success the
company was very happy with the
operation
that it turned out that way that's
another example of something that could
happen a real
uh everyday occurrence another one was
on a personal note
i was uh contracted by the president of
the democratic republic of congo
or i should say i was requested by him
he had not yet been elected it was a
controversial
election uh tccady was the uh price he's
the current president
a few years two years ago within 24
hours i had to get uh i got two agents
to accompany me and i flew to the drc no
weapons
it was a lot of political violence i
think something like over 900 people had
been killed in political violence in the
country
we went to kinsasha and uh i was kind
i was advising the soon to be hopefully
elected president because the former
president kabila
was a dictator for 20 years and it was
serious security concerns
so he brought me there to uh guide him
in this during this month or so the
supreme court in their country
was determining who would be in fact the
new president they
because they said there was election
fraud in any case he ended up becoming
the president i was there the night he
got sworn in we were worried about
violence
but i would say that that is that was a
high threat
protection detail for sure we had no
weapons
um and uh it was a lot of experience
it's another reason i like the military
people
for the high threat operations i had two
top tier people
retired of former marine infantry and a
former green beret
who within 24-hour notice were with me
at the airport with a goat bag ready to
go
to fly to africa we landed we didn't
even have a visa the president newly
elected president
soon to be elected president said just
just fly over don't worry i'll take care
of it and we were detained
in a dark room with police we had a
language barrier for a few hours
well there's a lot of challenges like i
said you have to be able to handle
stress well
and i find that the the military people
the high threat regions they're the way
to go for sure
they're they you know there's nowhere
they won't travel and they don't get
um stressed out they don't they don't
get nervous very easily
more than uh interesting military more
than uh
oh yeah yeah i'm not i wouldn't bring
law enforcement overseas to regions like
that it's all military
it's usually special operations people
got it who who have been deployed
obviously who have experience being
deployed right
there i've never been deployed those who
have been deployed have experienced what
it's like to be deployed so there's a
little bit
more uh awareness when a crisis happened
and how you responded to it
even myself you know if i had not had
the experience in the military
and operating in samara iraq where it
was a highly dangerous city lola city
it made it much uh more manageable
flying over to the drc
and uh you know you know how to handle
yourself like i said before
most of this job is communications and
understanding how to handle people
to make good judgment calls so much more
than
firearms proficiency and uh and mixed
martial arts
really communications and good judgment
is the most important
weapons we have so so question as far as
eyeballs on what you're looking at so
say a a husband and wife they have three
kids i have three kids one on the way we
go into a house and we're thinking about
you know renting this house for
christmas or for whatever okay
let's let's rent this out i look at the
house i'm like okay
nice pool big theater room pretty cool i
like it here
versus her eyes will look at their sharp
edges on these tables
it's too low okay this step
the kids are going to follow over this
step because they're going to run and
they're going to fall and
so the the eyes are seeing two different
things same home
same city same situation but different
lens when you walk into a place
yourself forget about you with a client
you're walking into a restaurant
because you know once you live the life
that you live you can't help but be like
that 24 7 because you're wired that way
what are you looking for when you go
into a restaurant what things are you
looking for when you go out and
you know you're you're going out into a
place where other people are there
yeah so there's two sides to that first
of all as a law enforcement officer my
whole
life basically adult life uh i go to a
restaurant it's a common joke
my family knows to let me sit with my
back against the wall so i could see the
door
they positioned themselves they've been
trained since they're little they know
how i
how i operate because i want to know if
something comes in i want to be able to
address it i don't like my back being
faced to the door
so it's very similar in protection work
when i go into assess say i'm going to
do an advanced site visit that's what we
call it
the principal is going to be going to a
restaurant for a meeting tomorrow night
we go ahead of time we're going to check
where the exits are what ex what
entrance do we want to bring them in
depending on your principle could we
bring them in a side entrance or a back
entrance so we could avoid crowds
um sometimes they won't want that
they're like no no i don't like that i
want to come in like everyone else
they all have different preferences i've
had a principal said don't hold doors
for me i don't like it
so we didn't hold doors which is you
know being raised the way i was it's a
common gesture right it's what i do for
everybody
um but but you you have to adjust to
your principle
when i'm going into this restaurant what
type of people are here is there
drinking here
they have cameras in here where the
doors the exits is there a room in this
place i could bring this person and use
it as a safe room if i had to
very quickly just until we could get
help
how where am i going to position my
vehicle is there a point of contact
sometimes when we go there we'll meet
with a manager say listen i'm gonna be
bringing someone here tomorrow
in certain area places they're used to
it they've dealt with it before
and uh hotels you know you go to the
four seasons they've dealt with
protection details they get it
you know they know firsthand what you're
doing you're gonna you want to know
all of these things where can my vehicle
be staged and they'll work with you on
that too they want
your principal to come to their place
they want them to have a successful
visit to their location so there's so
much that's part of it a site visit i do
it every time i walk in a place
just you know it's ingrained in you i i
bet
and and last but not least before we
wrap this up
is uh i'm in sales
so a big part of my business is body
language right so i need to sit there
and say okay
the wife doesn't trust me yet let's see
what i can do to break the ice
the husband is disinterested he has no
interest in what i'm talking about right
now how do i gain his interest
you know i have the two kids over there
that are being allowed the audio of the
tv is at 46.
i can't sell at 46. what do i need to do
to get the kids to calm down because
mom's already looked back seven times
she's worried
so you're looking at all this stuff
kitchen table where do we sit do i sit
with my bag
towards where the tv's back to or the
tv's back here
you know do i sit to be on the side of
them to feel like we're on this
everything is a bit of psychology when
you're
selling and when you're around long
enough and you're losing up sales and
you're broke you have to improve or
you're going to go
and not make it right so what what are
you looking for
signs of threat of a you're looking at
somebody and you're saying
there's some irregular you know not
normal behavior that guy has got going
on and i'm gonna keep my eye on that guy
what is he up to what are some things
you look for in somebody that triggers
something to say
i'm not saying he's gonna do something
right now but that's somebody i gotta
have my eye on
what do you look for right so there's a
few things there
um the first thing obviously anyone who
you do have a bullet for be on the
lookout
you have information on someone you're
always scanning for them if they show up
at an event that's a problem you have to
address immediately
aside from that anyone who would have an
unnatural
interest in your principle that's a
concern you're always a question i'm
asking here's a question i'm asking i'm
asking
not your job assume it's the it's me
like i don't do what you
assume a private citizen that's watching
this right now you keep hearing about
all this stuff and people are concerned
where a parent who has kids a husband
who's trying to protect the wife and the
family or
you know a mother who's going out that
wants to say okay maybe it's time we
leave i'm not going to stick around here
because that guy's giving
what things what things can you share
with us as the public not you right
that we can learn from you to say here's
some things to look out for where you
may want to behave this way
and do this that's the question yeah so
very similar very
similar to what i would do right is what
i would explain one thing is like i said
anyone who is uh anyone first of all
who's acting irrationally
abnormally maybe someone is emotionally
disturbed let's face it you run into
those people
all the time in society it's the way it
is um
they're a concern wherever you are you
should have a heightened sense of
awareness with those people because
they're
they're erratic and you're not sure what
might happen um
another thing is anyone like i mentioned
who you notice seems to have an
unnatural
um interest saying your children when
you go someplace or you
or yourself that's of concern you know
people
doesn't necessarily take training
everyone has training it's called life
right you've been around you you know
what's normal when it's not
you and when something's wrong your
instincts will kick in you might not
even know why
but if someone's acting not not normal
or naturally
it's really easy to pick up on when you
think about it
so anyone who has an unnatural interest
in you your children family
anyone who's acting abnormally or
emotionally disturbed in that sense
those are really what you're looking for
also if you had someone you've always
heard this right
someone who's just doesn't fit in right
like somebody who comes in they seem
really nervous maybe they're sweating a
lot maybe they're wearing inappropriate
clothing
for the climate or the location you're
in that's what picks up my interest
i'll notice it right away i'm like
that's strange why would they do that i
could give you a good example
and anyone could develop these skills i
drive into my neighborhood
i'll come home and i'll walk in my house
and i'll tell my wife
did you see that um that blue jeep
parked three house away she's like no i
have no idea what you're talking about
i notice it because it's never there
and it's been there for two days why is
it there you know
i'll say that and she goes you're crazy
i'm not crazy and a lot of the times
i've said that
there was an issue maybe it was
abandoned or maybe there was an issue
a lot of times i'll be driving home i
see something like that in my
neighborhood i get the phone out i get a
picture i get to play
never know what might happen later and
now i have it you know um
you would be surprised when you put a
little thought into it just a regular
person
you could do the same thing when things
are abnormal and some
some people i've met who've never been
in law enforcement they have good
inherent skills i've seen it and they
they have good observation skills and
they notice when things are a little
different
you know and people can train themselves
that way to improve that in this day and
age let's be honest
people should right there's a lot of
threats i i totally agree
do you recommend no matter how much
money somebody makes you know whether
i'm a
50 000 person or 200 000 executive do
you recommend having cameras around the
house workplace
what are your thoughts on cameras so you
can watch it on your phone and if yes is
there any recommendations yeah
so yes what i would say is this you
should definitely
uh rather than not of course for two
reasons one of them the most important
reason
is a deterrent you know people see
cameras bad guys see cameras they're
gonna come and
maybe see if your door's open in your
car something as small as that
maybe they're going in to do a burglary
during the day they see cameras they're
going to go to the next house
they're going to go to the next house
because they don't have cameras so i
always say you never want to be the
softest target on your stream
you want to be the hard target let them
go to the next one i don't know what to
say yeah
too bad for them what i would also say
from practical experience as a detective
and
in the private sector a lot of times
cameras don't
after the fact the crime has happened
it's not always that easy to use them to
identify people they're not that
accurate look at today's day and age
people have mass on right i mean it's
it's that's a an
obstacle right but the deterrent factor
is strong and they can be used to id
people they are successful in that
as far as the quality listen there's a
lot of really good systems out there
that like simply safe right i don't want
to draw brand names but i will i mean
level
you don't have to spend a tremendous
amount of money
to have a good system decent resolution
infrared capability outside inside
uh and and they're all accessible right
on your phone
that you can access while you're at work
while you're out to dinner
they'll send alarms to them and they're
cheap they're not expensive so
you don't have to spend a lot of money i
i tell my clients in this business you
have to guard against
companies they want to sell you the most
expensive stuff there is and mark it up
i tell people anything's better than
nothing and a lot of these systems
that are very affordable they're decent
they're they're good quality
so so it's interesting what you said so
so the idea of having the small cameras
that nobody sees at a house is not good
you want the camera for the person to
know
i have cameras at my house it's like an
announcement you're making you don't
want it to be the small ones that nobody
sees
well i would i would represent to say
like both i like for deterrent factor
the big ones people could see
but having a covert camera is not a bad
idea too so if they think that they've
gotten around they've they've uh um
bypassed your camera
maybe they didn't because they don't see
the other one you know
there's so much there's inside your
house too what if they do get in
maybe you have a camera in it that's
covert that that's going to pick up on
that
that's also based on privacy issues you
know
i've had some clients they're
celebrities they do not want anything
wi-fi
based in their home they have a fear
that someone could tap into that
and get video of them in their own home
so you have to
you have to um get the appropriate
system
for the right person the right client
very good point
and this is why we have guests like you
to get smarter i feel like
in the last 59 minutes i have become
smarter
because of you you know this is a very
educational uh uh last hour
and what a story you got and you know it
before we wrap this up
where can people find you obviously
we're gonna put your linkedin below
we're gonna put all your
links on where people find you but is
there a website is there one main place
where people can find you if they have
more questions
that's right global threat solutions
that's our company's website and through
that website
uh you know as you mentioned i'll give
you all of my uh social media info and
links
but through that website
globalthreadsolutions.com
they can find they can get in touch with
not in not only representatives of my
company but
myself one thing we pride ourselves in a
lot of companies in this industry have
got they get very big they're corporate
and they lose quality client has a
problem these are important people our
clients
they're talking to some supervisor or
maybe an operations manager
my clients 24 hours a day can get me on
the phone and i can tell you it's a big
selling point
this is a concierge service like you
mentioned before people spending a lot
of money
they don't want to be talking to a
supervisor when they have a real problem
they want to talk to me and that's what
they get
well we're going to put all the link
below where people can get a hold of you
and if
any questions they have but with that
being said kenneth thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment this was
one word wonderful
thank you it was great being on the show
i really appreciate it appreciate you
buddy you know i got to tell you when
the team first brought up his name that
hey pat would you like to interview him
i looked him up i'm like there's not a
lot on him i don't know so i thought
about it i said let's do it and i did it
and i just told him right now you didn't
see it but i told them privately
i learned a lot and i'm sure there's
going to be something that anybody
who is a civilian can learn a lot from
it and apply it but what a fascinating
interview i got so educated about the
whole world and i hope you did as well
and if you enjoyed this interview
there's another interview i did which we
talked about in the interview clint hill
former secret service agent for for
president and jackie kennedy it's got a
few million views i think six or seven
million views
if you've not watched it it's a must
watch click over to go watch it take
care everybody bye